CONGRESSMAN ADAM KINZINGER JOINS
ME NOW.
THANKS FOR TAKING THE TIME THIS
MORNING.
>> YOU BET.
>> YOU SPEAK ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY IN YOUR CLOSING
STATEMENT THERE.
YOU SAID TO OUR MANU RAJU AS YOU
LEFT YESTERDAY THAT YOU BELIEVE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS
CRIMINAL EXPOSURE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE HAS
PRESENTED SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
FOR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO
INDICT THE FORMER PRESIDENT?
>> YEAH, LOOK, AGAIN, IT'S A
QUESTION FOR JUSTICE.
I THINK WE HAVE PROVEN NOT
BASICALLY JUST IN THIS HEARING,
WE'VE PROVEN DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF A CRIMINAL CASE
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP OR PEOPLE
AROUND HIM IN EVERY HEARING, AND
I THINK TAKEN IN TOTALITY THIS
REPRESENTS THE GREATEST EFFORT
TO OVERTURN THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE, TO CONSPIRE AGAINST THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE, TO CONSPIRE
AGAINST AMERICAN DEMOCRACY THAT
WE'VE EVER HAD, FRANKLY, SINCE
THE CIVIL WAR.
SO YEAH, I THINK WE'VE PROVEN
THAT.
IT'S UP TO JUSTICE NOW TO MAKE A
DECISION.
LOOK, JIM, I WANT TO BE CLEAR --
WE DON'T WANT TO BECOME A
COUNTRY THAT THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION PROSECUTES THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION.
THAT HAPPENS IN FAILED
DEMOCRACIES.
BUT THIS IS A DIFFERENT
SITUATION.
IF WE BECOME A COUNTRY THAT
ACCEPTS ATTEMPTS AT COUPS AND
ATTEMPTS AT OVERCOMING THE WILL
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE CAN'T
SURVIVE THAT.
WE LITERALLY CANNOT SURVIVE
THAT.
AND THAT IN AND OF ITSELF IS A
PRECEDENT WHICH IS UNSUSTAINABLE
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
>> WE MAY HAVE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCING ANOTHER RUN
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS.
WE HAVE ELECTION DENIERS WHO
HAVE WON REPUBLICAN PRIMARIES IN
SOME STATES.
YOU SAID DURING LAST NIGHT'S
HEARING THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL
ALSO PROPOSE LAWS, REFORMS THAT
NEED TO BE MADE TO PREVENT THIS
FROM HAPPENING AGAIN.
WHAT SPECIFIC LAWS, CHANGES,
REFORMS, DO YOU BELIEVE ARE
NECESSARY?
>> LOOK, THAT'S A CONVERSATION
WE'RE ENGAGING IN.
LOOK, I THINK FOR SURE WE ALL
AGREE THAT THERE HAS TO BE
SOMETHING TO THE ELECTORAL COUNT
ACT.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S -- IF YOU LOOK
AT 2024, IF YOU RUN THE SAME
PLAYBOOK THAT WAS RUN IN 2020,
YOU CAN THEORETICALLY SEE HOW
YOU CAN MAKE IT SUCCEED IN 2024.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE CAN
DO IS PUT A ROADBLOCK UP AT
LEAST IN THE NEAR TERM, AND THEN
LONG TERM I THINK WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW, WHAT IS IT
-- WHAT DOES REALLY ONE VOTE
MEAN, HOW DID WE MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE FAITH IN THEIR VOTE,
AND HOW DO WE -- YOU KNOW,
WITHOUT VIOLATING THE FIRST
AMENDMENT, HOW DO YOU PENALIZE
PEOPLE FROM UNDERMINING THIS
DEMOCRACY?
AND I GOT TO TELL YOU,
OTHERWISE, TOO, THIS IS A LONGER
CONVERSATION, BUT MONEY AND
POLITICS -- WE'VE BECOME A
COUNTRY WHERE IT'S BILLIONAIRES
THAT ARE RUNNING FOR OFFICE AND
BILLIONAIRES THAT ARE FUNDING
RUNS FOR OFFICE.
AND WE CAN START TO SEE WHERE AT
THE BEGINNING OF WHAT YOU SEE IN
PLACES LIKE RUSSIA WITH OLD
GASHES DRIVING THE -- OLIGARCHS
DRIVING THE POLITICAL SYSTEM.
>> WE ARE FOUR MONTHS AWAY FROM
A MIDTERM ELECTION, TWO YEARS
AND FOUR MONTHS AWAY FROM A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS OF THE LAWS
YOU'VE PRESENTED.
BY THE WAY, THERE IS BIPARTISAN
MOVEMENT TOWARD POTENTIAL REFORM
OF THE ELECTORAL COUNT ACT.
BUT FOR FOLKS WATCHING RIGHT
NOW, SHOULD THEY FEEL CONFIDENT
THAT THE COMING ELECTIONS ARE
ANY SAFER FROM THIS KIND OF
ATTEMPT TO STEAL AN ELECTION
THAN THEY WERE IN 2020?
>> PROBABLY IN 2022, YES.
2024, NO.
LOOK, IT'S -- YOU KNOW, I LIKE
TO STAND UP AND BE MORE
OPTIMISTIC.
HERE'S THE DEAL -- AMERICA, YOU
DESERVE WAY BETTER THAN WHAT IS
REPRESENTING YOU OUT HERE.
YOU DESERVE WAY BETTER THAN
FRANKLY TWO PARTIES THAT ARE
REALLY JUST ENTRENCHEDED IN WHAT
IT MEANS TO TAKE POWER, HOW TO
TAKE POWER BACK, AND REPUBLICANS
IN PARTICULAR, LET ME TALK TO
YOU.
YOU DESERVE FAR BETTER THAN
SOMEBODY THAT'S GOING TO STAND
IN FRONT OF YOU, KNOWINGLY LIE
TO YOU SO THEY CAN STEAL YOUR
MONEY FROM YOU AND TELL YOU LIES
SO THAT YOU BELIEVE IT AND THEY
LAUGH BEHIND YOUR BACK.
TRUST ME, THEY ARE LAUGHING THAT
THEY CAN MANIPULATE YOU SO
EASILY.
SO YOU CAN GET MAD AT PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF AND LIZ CHENEY FOR
TELLING YOU THE TRUTH, BUT THE
PEOPLE YOU SHOULD BE MAD AT ARE
THOSE THAT ARE LYING TO YOU AND
COMPLETELY DISGRACING YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO AS
AMERICANS SAY IF OUR PARTIES
AREN'T GOING TO REPRESENT US, WE
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
DANG IT, IT'S UP TO US TO TAKE
OUR PARTY BACK.
>> AS YOU KNOW, BUBBLES IN THIS
COUNTRY, NEWS AND INFORMATION
BUBBLES, ARE PERSISTENT, AND
THESE HEARINGS ARE EITHER
COVERED DIFFERENTLY OR NOT
COVERED AT ALL, FRANKLY, IN SOME
RIGHT-WING MEDIA.
AND THAT IS SEEN, IT'S
DISCERNIBLE IN SOME OF THE
POLLING.
A MONMOUTH POLL RECENTLY ASKED
REPUBLICANS IN JUNE, 2021, AND
JUNE, 2022, HOW THEY WOULD
DESCRIBE JANUARY 6th, AND A
SMALLER NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS
BELIEVE TODAY THAT IT WAS AN
INSURRECTION THAN BELIEVED THEN.
DO YOU BELIEVE -- LOOK AT THAT
THERE FROM 33% IN JUNE, 2021, TO
JUST 13% TODAY, DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT THESE HEARINGS HAVE FAILED
TO MOVE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
VOTERS IN YOUR PARTY?
>> WELL, YEAH.
I MEAN, PROBABLY THE VAST
MAJORITY.
I'VE HAD A LOT OF ANECDOTAL
PEOPLE CALL AND SAY -- A GOOD
FRIEND SAID MY DAD WAS A SUPER
MAGA -- HE HATED ADAM AND LOVED
DONALD TRUMP.
HE'S ALL IN AGAINST DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES HE'S BEEN
LIED TO.
BUT LOOK, JIM, YEAH, THERE MAY
BE A CERTAIN SET OF VOTERS THAT
WILL NEVER PAY ATTENTION.
THEIR KIDS WILL.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU, I TRULY
BELIEVE IN MY HEART IN FIVE
YEARS, MAYBE NOT FIVE BUT
DEFINITELY TEN, YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO FIND A SINGLE
PERSON THAT ADMITS TO SUPPORTING
OR VOTING FOR DONALD TRUMP IN
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE EMBARRASSED BECAUSE
THEIR KIDS ARE GOING TO SAY YOU
ACTUALLY SUPPORTED DONALD TRUMP?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE LIKE,
NO, NO, WE DIDN'T -- LIKE TRYING
TO FIND A NIXON SUPPORTERS A
COUPLE OF YEARS AFTER HE
RESIGNED.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, YOUR KIDS --
TO MY FELLOW REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMEN, STANDS UP AND SPEAK
OUT, OR YOUR KIDS WILL BE
ASHAMED OF SHAVING THAT LAST
NAME.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT TO BE MEAN.
THAT'S JUST FACT.
>> THE COMMITTEE MADE CLEAR THE
HEARING WAS NOT THE LAST ONE,
LIKELY TO CONTINUE INTO
SEPTEMBER.
WHAT ARE THOSE HEARINGS -- WHAT
SHOULD FOLKS AT HOME EXPECT THEM
TO FOCUS ON?
>> SO YOU KNOW, RIGHT NOW AS WE
KIND OF FORESEE IT, IT WILL BE
MORE LIKE WE'RE GOING TO START
THIS INTERIM REPORT GATHERING,
AS WE CONTINUE TO GET MORE
INFORMATION AND KEEP THIS GOING.
SO I THINK YOU COULD SEE A
COUPLE OF KINDS OF THINGS.
I DON'T KNOW THIS FOR SURE,
WHAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE YET.
ANY NEW INFORMATION WE GET
THAT'S RELEVANT, THAT'S
IMPORTANCE TO PUT IN FRONT --
IMPORTANT TO PUT IN FRONT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, OR ABOUT THE
REPORT SUMMARIZING
RECOMMENDATIONS.
MAYBE TALKING TO NATIONAL
SECURITY EXPERTS ABOUT WHAT DOES
THIS DO TO AMERICA'S NATIONAL
DEFENSE.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS KIND OF MIFFS E-- OF MISSED
IN THE HEARING, KEITH KELLOGG
SAID DONALD TRUMP NEVER
REQUESTED NATIONAL GUARD.
THIS IS WHAT I KEEP HEARING BY
MY FRIENDS ON THE RIGHT IS WHAT
ABOUT THE NATIONAL GUARD?
DONALD TRUMP REQUESTED THE
NATIONAL GUARD -- TONS OF PEOPLE
SAID HE DIDN'T.
HE DIDN'T.
LET'S PUT THAT OUT THERE, TOO.
SO THOSE ARE KINDS OF THINGS WE
CAN SEE IN THE FUTURE.
>> YEAH.
ONE THING THE COMMITTEE HAS
ATTEMPTED TO DO LAST NIGHT AND
IN THE DAYS BEFORE IS TO
CORROBORATE CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S
TESTIMONY ON A NUMBER OF FRONTS
BUT INCLUDING THIS ALLEGED
INCIDENT IN THE PRESIDENTIAL SUV
WITH HIM WANTING TO GO TO THE
CAPITOL FOLLOWING THE RALLY ON
THE ELLIPSE.
YOU'LL REMEMBER IN THE WAKE OF
THAT TESTIMONY THAT THE U.S.
SECRET SERVICE SEEMED TO IMPLY
AND OTHERS THROUGH UNNAMED
SOURCES THAT THERE WERE MEMBERS
INCLUDING TONY ORNATO, THE
DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF, WHO WOULD
DISPUTE THAT TESTIMONY.
U.S. SECRET SERVICE ALSO SAID AT
THE TIME THAT THEY WOULD BE
COOPERATIVE.
ZOE LOFGREN SAID LAST NIGHT THAT
ORNADO AS WELL AS OTHERS HAVE
NOW -- ROBERT ENGLE, HAVE
LAWYERED UP, AND THE DRIVER OF
THE SUV.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT THEY'RE STILL
GOING COOPERATE?
>> NO.
IT'S ONE THING TO THROUGH AN
ANONYMOUS SOURCE -- I'LL GIVE IT
TO THEM.
AFTER CASSIDY TESTIFIED, ON THE
RIGHT THEY WERE TOTALLY
DISCREDITING HER OR TRYING TO BY
SAYING, YOU KNOW, LOOK, THE
THING -- WE HEAR THIS ANONYMOUS
SOURCE THAT SAID IT WASN'T TRUE.
NOW OF COURSE THAT'S MELTED
AWAY.
YOU'VE HAD CORROBORATION OF HER
STORY.
SHE NEVER SAID SHE SAW IT IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
SHE SAID SHE HEARD IT.
NOW ALL THE SUDDEN YOU HAVE
SECRET SERVICE MEMBERS LAWYERING
UP AND NOT TALKING TO US.
SO THE POINT IS IF YOU'RE GOING
TO INVEST EVERYTHING IN TRYING
TO DISCREDIT A VERY CREDIBLE
WITNESS, YOU BETTER MAKE SURE
YOU CAN DO IT.
THEY FAILED TO.
SHE IS UNIMPEACHABLE, AND
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON, SHE NEVER
INTENDED THIS, SHE WILL GO DOWN
IN HISTORY LIKE BLOWING AWAY
ANYBODY ELSE THAT'S BEEN PART OF
THE JANUARY 6th STUFF.
THAT'S NOT WHAT SHE WANTS, BUT
SHE'S A HUGE HERO.
>> A SHORT TIME AGO YOU SHARED
SOME OF THE MESSAGES INCLUDING
VOICEMAIL MESSAGES THAT YOU HAVE
RECEIVED FROM PEOPLE THREATENING
YOU FOR THE WORK YOU'VE DONE ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
YOU HAD A VERY PROMINENT ROLE
LAST NIGHT.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO EXPOSE
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT PUT YOU IN A
BAD POSITION, BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR FOLKS TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS IN THAT KIND OF SPACE.
ARE YOU STILL GETTING THREATS?
DID YOU GET MORE THREATS AFTER
YOUR COMMENTS LAST NIGHT?
>> I'M SURE I HAVE SINCE LAST
NIGHT.
I HAVE SINCE I'VE PUT THAT OUT.
I MEAN -- JIM, LOOK, THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT CALL AND THREATEN
MY CHILD, WHO'S 6 MONTHS OLD,
AND HATHAT TAKES PURE EVIL.
DON'T EVER TALK TO ME -- I'M A
CHRISTIAN.
DON'T TALK TO ME ABOUT YOU BEING
A CHRISTIAN AND THREATEN TO KILL
A 6-MONTH-OLD BABY.
WHAT KIND OF EVIL IS IN YOUR
HEART.
IF THAT'S A PARTY -- I WANT
NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT.
AND SO YEAH, THERE ARE SOME PURE
EVIL -- TALK TO ANYBODY, TALK TO
ANYBODY THAT IS IN THIS
POSITION.
I'M SURE YOU GET THE SAME THING.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, A TOUGH
MAN DOESN'T NEED TO CALL AND
THREATEN A CHILD AND A WIFE OF A
MAN.
>> YEAH.
IT'S FALSE STRENGTH.
I HAVE EXPERIENCED IT.
CONGRESSMAN KINZINGER, BE SAFE.
>> THANKS.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR STRAIGHT
TALK, AND WE APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE TIME THIS MORNING.
>> YOU BET.
TAKE CARE.